[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka naabend und
plötzlich fällt das Tabu seit
Kriegsbeginn seit bald zehn Monaten
Werten Kanzleramt und
Verteidigungsministerin alle Fragen nach
deutschen Panzern für die Ukraine ab mit
den immer gleichen Argumenten keine
Alleingänge die anderen liefern auch
keine Panzer westlicher Bauart die sind
auch schwierig zu handhaben und außerdem
haben wir für uns selbst nicht genug und
nun geht's doch nach einem
Telefongespräch zwischen Olaf Scholz und
US-Präsident Joe Biden gab es jetzt am
Abend eine gemeinsame Erklärung es
werden amerikanische und deutsche
Schützenpanzer geliefert und weitere
Patriot Abwehrsysteme von amerikanischer
Seite gab es noch eine weitere Botschaft
an Putin dass man sein Angebot am
orthodoxen Weihnachtstag eine Feuerpause
einzulegen für eine taktische fit halten
Andreas
für die russischen Abendnachrichten ist
die Anordnung Putins so wichtig dass Sie
Wort für Wort wiedergegeben wird
Waffenruhe am orthodoxen Weihnachten an
allen Fronten der militärischen
spezialoperation angeordnet vom Mittag
des morgigen Tages 12 Uhr bis zum 7
Januar 24 Uhr
die Reaktionen den westlichen
Hauptstädten tiefes Misstrauen Putin
wolle den Krieg nicht unterbrechen
sondern gewinnen
ich zögere auf irgendetwas zu antworten
was Putin sagt er war bereit
Krankenhäuser Kindergärten und Kirchen
zu bombardieren am 25 Dezember genauso
wie ein neuer ich glaube er will sich
nur etwas Luft verschaffen
[Musik]
dann geht beiden telefonieren mit Paris
mit Berlin mit Kiew Putins Angriffe das
Kriegsgeschehen bewegen den Westen
seiner Hilfe für die Ukraine zu
verstärken die USA kündigen an den
Schützenpanzer Bradley zu liefern
Frankreich kündigt an den spätpanzer
amx-10 RC zu liefern und Deutschland
kündigt am Abend an nun doch den
Schützenpanzer Marder zu liefern mit dem
die Ukraine ihre wiedergewonnenen
Gebiete absichern kann wie es die
Opposition seit Monaten fordert es geht
ja darum dass die Erfolge auch gesichert
werden und dafür braucht man dem
Artillerie im Flugabwehr auch Panzer
Schützenpanzer und Kampfpanzer darüber
sind sich militärisch alle einig es gibt
kein militärisches Argument diese Panzer
nicht zu liefern das politische Argument
gegen die panzerlieferung haben macron
haben beide dem deutschen Kanzler heute
aus der Hand genommen es war Scholz
ultra es wird keine deutschen
Alleingänge geben wir werden keine
Alleingänge machen es gibt keine
deutschen Alleingänge es darf keine
deutschen Alleingänge geben deutsche
alleinnengänge wären falsch es ist nicht
ganz klar ob der Anstoß für den
gemeinsamen Gang er aus Washington oder
eher aus Paris kam in London bei bärbox
Antrittsbesuch hört man heraus aus
Berlin kam er nicht
wir haben den Horror der letzten Wochen
glaube ich alle noch direkt in uns und
deswegen haben sowohl ja die USA als
auch Frankreich gemeinsam überlegt wie
sie besser unterstützen können und
genauso überlegen wie auch als
Bundesregierung wieder aufs Neue was wir
gemeinsam mit unseren Partnern tun
können der Marder ist kein Kampfpanzer
von deren Lieferung ist nicht die Rede
aber er bietet ähnlichen Schutz und ist
mit dringend benötigten lenkflugwaffen
ausgerüstet aus Russland werden Züge
Weise schützen später und Kampfpanzer in
den Kampf gegen die Ukraine gebracht
ohne
Opposition ohne Diskussion
Professor Kahlo Masala von der
Universität der Bundeswehr in München
ist uns zugeschaltet guten Abend
Professor Masala
schönen guten Abend
auf diese Panzer hat die Ukraine lange
gewartet da hat sie lange drum gebeten
fast von Anfang an wie erklären Sie sich
jetzt diesen Umschwung im westlichen
Bündnis wie interpretieren sie das
ich glaube der Umschwung ist durch zwei
Entwicklungen zu erklären zum einen ist
er zu erklären dass in den vergangenen
Wochen Russland einen unglaublichen
raketenkrieg gegen die zivile
Infrastruktur dieses Landes und gegen
die Zivilisten geführt hat und keinerlei
Anstalten machte diesen auch irgendwie
einzuhalten sondern man hatte den
Eindruck russland will die Ukraine in
die Steinzeit zurückkommen und zum
zweiten ist es sicherlich auch die
endgültige Enttäuschung und die Absage
an die Idee dass ich Putin ohne
Vorbedingungen oder mit anderen
Vorbedingungen als Russland sie stellt
an den Verhandlungstisch begibt um einen
Friedensschluss mit der Ukraine zu
suchen etwas was er ja heute wiederum
abgelehnt hat und ich glaube in dieser
Kombination ist dann diese
selbstgesetzte Linie sie haben vom
Tabubruch geredet davon würde ich auch
reden aber diese selbst gesteckte Linie
der westlichen Staaten keine modernen
westlichen gepanzerten Systeme zu
liefern die ist dann gefallen und das
hat zu der Entscheidung geführt die wir
heute erlebt haben von eskalationsgefahr
ist auch keine Rede mehr
das ist ja genau der Punkt also man hat
ja immer argumentiert und sie hatten die
Einspieler ja auch von Olaf Scholz der
in Interviews immer gesagt hat der
Marder und der Leo würden eine
Eskalation bedeuten das Argument war
schon nicht mehr haltbar nachdem man den
Geparden und die Panzerhaubitze 2000 in
die Ukraine geliefert hat aber es war
noch immer sozusagen das Mantra der
Bundesregierung oder des Bundeskanzlers
jetzt scheint man endlich begriffen zu
haben dass die Lieferung bestimmter
Waffensysteme nicht notwendigerweise zu
einer Eskalation führt sondern diese
Eskalation ganz alleine in der Hand von
Putin liegt egal was für Waffensysteme
man liefert oder nicht also könnte es
eventuell auch noch den Leo geben oder
Leo eins vielleicht dann eher
ich denke es ist ein Tabu gebrochen
worden und dieses Tabu beinhaltet dass
wir jetzt auch je nachdem wie der Krieg
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
weiterverlaufen wird auch über die Frage
von main battle Tanks also richtigen
Kampfpanzern das sind ja alles keine
Panzer die die richtigen Panzer die wir
jetzt liefern sondern richtige
Kampfpanzer im Sinne von Leo 2 oder
Leclerc oder Abrahams diskutieren werden
und wir werden auch sicherlich auch noch
mal die Frage diskutieren ob die in
osteuropäischen Staaten noch
existierenden alten sowjetischen
Kampfflugzeugen also die Micke 29 nicht
auch etwas wäre was man in die Ukraine
liefern sollte weil das ist genau das
Gerät dass die Ukraine in dieser Phase
des Krieges dringend benötigt du keine
wollte ja auch eben diese Schützenpanzer
und später Panzer haben also eben keine
schweren Kampfbahn aber die bringen
Infanterie nach hier und dort und haben
auch ziemlich dicke Kanonen dabei warum
ist ihnen das so wichtig da geht's doch
nicht mehr nur um etwas zu halten
sondern dann gehst doch wahrscheinlich
auch darum nach vorne zu kommen also die
Offensive zu kommen
richtig es geht hier vor allen Dingen
sozusagen darum bei den offensiven
besser operieren zu können Soldaten
schneller und Soldatinnen auch schneller
sozusagen zu Punkten zu bringen und
besser geschützt zu Punkten zu bringen
ich meine wir haben ja Bilder aus der
Ukraine wo Soldatinnen in Pickups an die
Front gefahren werden das ist natürlich
ein untragbarer Zustand zum Schutz der
eigenen Streitkräfte dieser ist jetzt
wesentlich verbessert und durch den
französischen spätpanzer kann das
gegebenenfalls dann auch noch mal Feuer
mäßig abgesichert werden also von daher
wird jetzt Material geliefert dass die
Ukraine dringend benötigt für ihre
offensiven und gegen offensiven in den
nächsten Wochen der Chef der Ukraine ist
ukrainische Militär Geheimdienstes hatte
ja angekündigt im März werde man eine
Frühlingsoffensive beginnen und sind
solche geheimdienstlichen Botschaften
auch immer mit Vorsicht zu genießen was
dahinter steckt aber da müssten sich
aber jetzt dann die Bundeswehr auch
beeilen um die Ukraine an den Mördern
auszubilden
also nach den letzten Informationen soll
die Ausbildung abgeschlossen sein im
ersten Quartal 2023 und dann sollen die
Ukraine mit dem Gerät sozusagen nach
Hause gehen und es dort einsetzen und
das ist in der Tat richtig also Zeit ist
hier der kritische Faktor das Gerät muss
relativ schnell in die Ukraine kommen
ich meine nicht nur die Ukraine wollen
offensiven machen die Russen bereiten
auch wiederum offensiven vor die aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach im Frühjahr
stattfinden die Ausbildung muss schnell
erfolgen das Gerät muss schnell in die
Ukraine kommen ansonsten laufen wir
wieder in die Falle dass wir die
richtige Entscheidung getroffen haben
aber viel zu spät sozusagen das Material
in die Ukraine bringen dann hat er Putin
diese Feuerpause diese weihnachtliche
angeboten und da sagen die Ukraine also
auch Kollegen von Ihnen internationale
Professoren von internationale
internationales Recht das ist eigentlich
nur eine Finte ist das ist so eine Art
Kommunikation in den Westen um jeden die
auch mit diesen Waffenlieferung Probleme
haben zu signalisieren eigentlich ganz
gesprächsbereit teilen Sie diese
Einschätzung
ich teile das also es ist zum einen
zynisch angesichts der Tatsache und Joe
Biden hat das ja in ihrem Bericht
erwähnt also das am 25 Dezember
Kinderkliniken bombardiert worden sind
das Silvesterraketen auf die Ukraine
herunter hagelte jetzt sozusagen diese
diese einseitige Feuerpause anzukündigen
ich glaube das ist motiviert einmal um
natürlich den Kritikern dieser
Waffenlieferung jetzt Munition zu
liefern zu sagen seht ja die Russen
bewegen sich sie rufen eine Feuerpause
aus das haben wir immer gewollt jetzt
lasst uns gucken was man daraus machen
kann zum zweiten ist es sicherlich eine
Kommunikation nach Russland hinein dass
man das orthodoxe Weihnachtsfest
respektiert und zum dritten hilft es
natürlich auch wenn diese Feuerpause
eingehalten werden sollte auch von den
Ukrainern was natürlich nicht erfolgen
wird aber dann ungestört sozusagen
weiterhin Material und Mensch an die
Front zu bringen und der vierte Punkt
ist und das haben wir ganz oft in
Kriegen und Bürger kriegen gesehen diese
Feuerpausen sind unglaublich brüchig
also da braucht es nicht viel damit man
die Gefechte wieder aufnimmt von daher
alles in allem glaube ich dass es
einfach eine zynische finde von Putin
und und seinen seinen Getreuen um hier
ein bisschen Zeit zu gewinnen
für das Gespräch
und dann schalten wir jetzt noch nach
Berlin zu unserer
hauptstadtkorrespondentinenpolitischen
und hier deutsch Deutschland politischen
Abläufe näher ansehen diese Kehrtwende
des Kanzlers man hat so ein bisschen
Eindruck hat zog man ihn halt danke hin
war ja war das doch abgestimmt in
irgendeiner Form mit Paris oder wurde
das Kanzleramt von macron gestern
ziemlich überrascht wie ist deine
Einschätzung also aus der SPD war heute
zu hören dass man dass die Partner schon
seit Dezember allgemein im Gespräch
gewesen sein über weitere Unterstützung
für die Ukraine und dass man nicht
überrascht worden sei von Macross
Vorstoß allerdings muss man sagen wenn
es wirklich eine gemeinsame Entscheidung
gewesen ist dann war es keine besonders
gut abgestimmte gemeinsame Kommunikation
denn gestern hat sich die
Bundesregierung erst einmal nicht
geäußert zur Erklärung von immer
manuellen macron heute gab es dann das
Telefonat des Bundeskanzlers mit dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten und danach
die meine Willenserklärung dass man also
Marder liefern werde es gab keinen
Zeitplan es gab keine Zahlen dazu und
wenn man sich so umhört und eingeweihten
Kreisen dann scheint auch noch nicht
klar zu sein woher diese Marder Panzer
dann kommen ob sie von der Bundeswehr
direkt geliefert werden ob sie von
Hersteller vom Hersteller geliefert
werden das sind alles Fragen die man bei
einer gut vorbereiteten Entscheidung
vielleicht auch hätte beantworten können
so bleibt jetzt momentan noch der
Eindruck da stehen das macron vielleicht
doch vorgepresst ist dann gab es in der
SPD ja gibt es vielleicht auch noch
immer große Vorbehalte gerade auch gegen
panzerlieferung wird dann Scholz dort
jetzt plötzlich dann doch die Zustimmung
für diesen Schritt finden
ja tatsächlich war ja die SPD die
einzige Partei in der Ampelkoalition die
sich da noch wesentlich gesperrt hat FDP
und Grüne hatten ja schon lange
gefordert dass man die Ukraine auch mit
Mardern unterstützt und die Grünen haben
das heute auch schon begrüßt den Schritt
und auch in der SPD tut sich
offensichtlich etwas der Verteidigung
verteidigungsexperte der SPD Helmig hat
den Schritt heute auch schon begrüßt
allerdings darauf hingewiesen dass es
eben wichtig ist dass er im Kontext mit
den Bündnispartnern geschieht und der
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzende im Bundestag
Rolf Mütze nicht hat sich dem auch
angeschlossen hat das ganze
situationsgerecht genannt und hat aber
auch noch mal die Abstimmung mit den
Partnern betont also es scheint so als
hätte Olaf Scholz es geschafft seine
Partei einzuschwören eben auf seine
Linie Entscheidungen nicht im Alleingang
zu treffen aber wenn die anderen
westlichen Verbündeten mitgehen dann
eben auch nicht zu blockieren die Frage
ist geht das jetzt nur für den Mörder
oder wird sich die Partei auch
anschließen wenn es jetzt dann demnächst
möglicherweise darum geht mit
Forderungen umzugehen nach weiteren
Panzerlieferungen Lieferungen zum
Beispiel nach leopardpanzern allerdings
schon gute Dankeschön für die
Einschätzung und dann blicken wir jetzt
nach Rom ein ehemaliger Papst wurde
beigesetzt und die Totenmesse hielt der
Papst das hat es in der Geschichte des
papstums seit Jahrhunderten nicht
gegeben für den Vatikan war es insofern
auch nicht ganz leicht damit umzugehen
für den Tod eines amtierenden Papstes
gibt es unendlich viele Regeln und
Rituale aber nicht für einen ehemaligen
Papst der vor zehn Jahren den Heiligen
Stuhl freiwillig räumte und sich danach
mehr oder weniger zurückzog das bot
heute aber auch eine gewisse
Gestaltungsfreiheit Andreas Postel
berichtet aus Rom
Trauer stille Andacht im Herzen der
Ewigen Stadt die Kuppel des Petersdoms
in römischen Morgennebel als der Sarg
aus Zedernholz zur Totenmesse für
Benedikt den 16 aufgebahrt ist
der Wunsch ist imitierten Papstes nach
einer schlichten Zeremonie sollte an
diesem außergewöhnlichen Tag erfüllt
werden ein Papst zelebriert das Requiem
für einen Papst das hat Rom seit 2
Jahrhunderten nicht erlebt
[Musik]
du treuer Freund des himmlischen
Bräutigams möge deine Freude vollkommen
sein wenn du seine Stimme endgültig und
für immer hörst
zur Totenmesse für den ersten deutschen
Papst seit fast 500 Jahren ist die
gesamte deutsche Staatsspitze angereist
[Musik]
verstorbene Papst war ein großer
Theologe
ausgestattet mit
kräftigem Intellekt
und ein Mann mit großer Bescheidenheit
mit etwa 50.000 sind zwar weniger
Menschen auf den Petersplatz gekommen
als vom Vatikan erwartet aber aus
Deutschland haben sich doch viele Pilger
auf den Weg gemacht für die
emotionalsten Momente sorgen ganz
sicherlich die Bayern auch aus Josef
Ratzingers Heimatgemeinde Pentling
er hat Feuerwehrautos eingeweiht er hat
Glockenweihe vorgenommen und er hat
immer diesen Kontakt zu der pentlinger
Bevölkerung gepflegt und darum haben wir
schöne Erinnerungen der Vorsitzende der
Deutschen Bischofskonferenz würde ich
den deutschen Papst ungeachtet zum
mancher Differenzen von der ist einer
von uns ist ein deutscher ist ein Bayer
und deshalb sind im auch großer
Sympathien zugeflogen und dennoch hat er
sich ja mit der Kirche in unserem Land
nicht immer leicht getan und er hat als
perfekt der Glaubenskongregation und
auch als Papst Entscheidungen getroffen
mit denen wir uns nicht leicht getan
haben
Santo subito Rufe nach einer sofortigen
Heiligsprechung wie beim jahrhundert
Papst Johannes Paul den zweiten gibt es
nur vereinzelt zu groß weil auch die
Last des sexuellen Missbrauchs in der
katholischen Kirche
ich würde auf gar keinen Fall
unterschreiben dass Papst Benedikt ein
großer Kämpfer gegen den Missbrauch war
und ich finde alleine die Stimmen die
wir gerade in Deutschland hören von
Betroffenen sexuellen Missbrauchs in der
katholischen Kirche zeigen ganz deutlich
dass auch die Betroffenen der
katholischen Kirche die Betroffenen von
sexuellen Missbrauchs nicht
unterschreiben
um das Bild Benedikt für die Ewigkeit
geht es kaum dass ein Leichnam in Holz
und Zink und Holz versiegelt beigesetzt
wird
in den vatikanischen Grotten in der
ehemaligen Gruft von Johannes Paul dem
zweiten hat Benedikt 16 nun seine letzte
Ruhe gefunden
und jetzt als Wolf mit anderen
Nachrichten die Gesundheitsminister von
Bund und Ländern haben sich auf erste
Schritte für eine krankenhausreform
verständigt sie wollen bis zur
Sommerpause einen gemeinsamen Vorschlag
erarbeiten im Mittelpunkt steht die
Klinik Finanzierung so könnten etwa die
Fallpauschalen gesenkt werden für
medizinisches Gerät und Personal ist
dagegen mehr Geld vorgesehen Ziel ist
den wirtschaftlichen Druck auf
Krankenhäuser zu verringern
wegen der rasant gestiegenen
coronazahlen in China führt nun auch
Deutschland eine testpflicht für
Einreisende aus der Volksrepublik ein
das teilt die Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach mit gestern hatten sich die
EU-Länder auf einen gemeinsames Vorgehen
verständigt neben der testpflicht sind
Stichproben an den Flughäfen geplant um
Virusvarianten zu erkennen auch soll es
ergänzende abwasserkontrollen für China
reisen geben
in Belarus hat ein Prozess gegen den
Friedensnobelpreisträger alles
pierlatsky begonnen er und seine mit
Angeklagten waren im Zuge der
monatelangen Demonstrationen gegen
Präsident Lukaschenko im Jahr 2020
verhaftet worden die Anklage steht im
Zusammenhang mit Zahlungen des von
balljahrski geleiteten
menschenrechtszentrums viasner an
politische Häftlinge im drohen bis zu 12
Jahre Haft
bei der Wahl zum Vorsitz des
US-Repräsentantenhauses zeichnet sich
kein Ende des Kräftemessens ab der
Republikaner mccasi schaltet offenbar
auch im gerade laufenden neunten
Wahlgang am Widerstand aus den eigenen
Reihen gegen ihn stellen sich bei den
Abstimmungen Abweichler aus dem rechten
Flügel der Partei trotz neuer
Zugeständnisse an seine Gegner die Wahl
läuft so lange bis ein Speaker gewählt
ist oder eine Mehrheit für Vertagung
stimmt
früher ging es eher um Fernseher heute
mehr um Autos die Elektronikmesse sess
in Las Vegas hat sich über die Zeit sehr
gewandelt bietet aber immer einen Blick
in die Zukunft wo geht es technologisch
hin was kommt als nächstes auf den Markt
im Fokus dabei die Konsumenten das macht
es für ein breites Publikum interessant
gerade in diesem Jahr nachdem die
vergangenen zwei Messen wegen Corona
stark ausgedünnt waren jetzt sind auch
die Großen der Branche zurück und
präsentieren ihre Visionen Benjamin
daniel war für uns in Las Vegas
wäre es nicht schön sich mit jedem
Menschen der Welt unterhalten zu können
ganz gleich welche Sprache man spricht
mit diesem Kopfhörern ist das möglich
denn sie können simultan übersetzen
Technik die unseren Alltag erleichtert
ob selbst kochende Küchenhelfer oder
schalldichte Masken für diskrete
Telefonate in der Öffentlichkeit auf der
Messe der digitalen Superlative ist so
ziemlich alles dabei wonach unsere
Technik Süchtige Gesellschaft giert
auch für die Autoindustrie ist die CES
mittlerweile eine der wichtigsten Messen
des Jahres so feierte am Abend der BMW
ivision die Weltpremiere mit seinem
visionsfahrzeug will der Konzern vor
allem einen Ausblick auf die digitale
Zukunft der Unternehmensgruppe geben
unter anderem mit Head-up-Display und
Frontscheibe die jeweils teilweise oder
vollständige virtuität abbilden können
dieses Auto wird natürlich nicht sehr
produziert werden aber die Elemente da
drin sind teilweise sehr sehr an einem
produktionsstaat und wir werden ja in
2025 die neue Klasse auf den Markt
bringen voll elektrisch und er war auch
mit einer ganz neuen
Ausprägung der digitalen
Fahrzeugeigenschaften der Mercedes
Prototyp eqxx sorgt aus einem anderen
Grund für Schlagzeilen der Elektrowagen
schafft mehr als 1.000 km mit nur einer
Batterie Ladung in Serie soll auch
dieser forschungswagen nicht gehen
Elemente jedoch sollen Eingang in
verschiedene Modelle finden
während die Pandemie nicht nur der
Autoindustrie massiven Schaden zugefügt
hat beschleunigte sie die
Digitalisierung noch weiter und so
strotzt die tech-branche vor Kraft was
auch bei der CES deutlich wird bei all
dem technologieoptimismus geraten
kritischer Aspekte manchmal in den
Hintergrund gerade beim Thema
Datenschutz klaffen die Ansichten in
Europa und den USA weit auseinander
definitiv ist es so dass viele der
Sachen die hier gezeigt werden Cloud
basiert sind also hier geht übers
Internet es werden viele Daten erhoben
das ist immer kritisch ich glaube dass
wir deswegen viele Lösungen die wir hier
sehen so in Europa nicht bekommen werden
ob das gut oder schlecht ist muss wohl
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden die
Nachfrage nach technischen Produkten
steigt jedenfalls überall auf der Welt
weiter und damit auch unsere
Abhängigkeit von ihnen
und mit Blick auf die Energiekrise gibt
es heute eine gute zumindest beruhigende
Nachricht Heinz damit gibt es bei dir
jetzt weiter die Bundesnetzagentur kommt
in ihrem neuen Lagebericht zur
Gasversorgung zu der Einschätzung dass
eine gasmangellage in diesem Winter
zunehmend unwahrscheinlich werde
allerdings verbunden mit der Warnung
dass seine Verschlechterung der
Situation weiterhin nicht ausgeschlossen
werden können und ein sparsamer
Gasverbrauch wichtig bleibe um Energie
geht es auch beim Besuch von
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck in Norwegen
dass derzeit Deutschlands größter
erdgaslieferant ist und jetzt geht es
auch um die Zusammenarbeit bei Energie-
ja der zentrale Punkt ist Wasserstoff er
soll ja künftig als klimafreundliche
Energieträger eine große Rolle bei uns
spielen in Stahlwerken könnte er die
Kohle und den Gaskraftwerken das Erdgas
ersetzen doch in Deutschland ist er noch
Mangelware ja und was Energie betrifft
ist Norwegen eine Supermacht in Europa
seit dem Aus für russisches Gas kommt
mehr als ein Drittel des deutschen
Bedarfs von dort nun also auch
Wasserstoff aus Norwegen durch eine
Pipeline 2030 soll sie fertig sein in
der Energie- und Klimakrise wollen beide
Länder nun langfristig eng
zusammenarbeiten aber nicht nur beim
Wasserstoff Habeck will mit Norwegen
auch bei der Entsorgung des
klimaschädlichen CO2 kooperieren dort
soll Kohlendioxid schon bald in
ehemaligen erdgaslagern im Meeresboden
gespeichert werden habe ich bemüht sich
die Vorbehalte von Umweltverbänden zu
zerstreuen
in Norwegen hat man jetzt jahrzehntelang
Erfahrung damit gemacht und das was
befürchtet wurde dass das CO2 wieder
entweicht und möglicherweise Schaden an
anderer Stelle anrichtet ist nicht
eingetreten für die Produktion des
norwegischen Wasserstoffs wird zunächst
noch Erdgas benötigt später dann soll
die Energie von Windparks kommen mit dem
Ziel grünen Wasserstoff nach Deutschland
zu liefern doch es ist so weit ist wird
es noch dauern weil reale vielen Dank
bei der 71 4 schanzentournee fällt
morgen in Bischofshofen die Entscheidung
über den Gesamtsieg heute stand die
Qualifikation zum vierten und letzten
Springen auf dem Programm dabei haben
sich alle sieben deutschen Skispringer
fürs morgige Finale qualifiziert
Tagesbester war der in der Gesamtwertung
führende Norweger
Biathlon Olympiasiegerin Denise Herrmann
Wick ist zum Jahresauftakt auf der
slowenischen Pokljuka sechste im Sprint
über siebeneinhalb Kilometer geworden
sie zeigte in der Loipe die schnellste
Laufzeit zwei Fehler am Schießstand
kostet die 34-Jährige aber am Ende einen
Podestplatz auf die fehlerfreie
schwedische Siegerin Elvira Ölberg wegen
letztlich 36,6 Sekunden 36,3
der deutsche Wintersport hat eine seiner
Ikonen verloren die wohl beliebteste
Skifahrerin die es hierzulande je gab
Rosi Mittermeier ist gestorben
durch ihre Olympiasiege 1976 wurde sie
über Nacht zu einem Star um sie brach
ein regelrechter Hype aus wie man heute
sagen würde das waren aber genau das was
so gar nicht zu ihr passt und ihr wohl
auch unheimlich war ihre aktive Karriere
als Leistungssportlerin beendete sie
jedenfalls früh ihre Popularität hat das
keinen Abbruch sie und die Mann
Christian Neureuther blieben
bundesdeutsche Institutionen mit einer
strahlenden Freundlichkeit die
ihresgleichen suchte ein Nachruf von
Barbara Look
Rosi auf dem Siegertreppchen
[Musik]
Deutschland aus dem Häuschen
ist das Jahr 1976 für Rosi Mittermeier
das Madl von der Winkelmoosalm ist hier
nach nichts mehr so wie vorher
das war Wahnsinn also ich konnte die
nicht auf der Winkel muss so in Ruhe
leben ich bin hinten beim Finstern
ausgestiegen im Wald gegangen und so
weiter kamen die Musikkapellen auf und
Hamburg
Souvenir
Rosi Mittermeier wird in den bayerischen
Bergen quasi auf Skiern groß ihre Eltern
besitzen einen Gasthaus mit Skischule
rosi ist ein Naturkind abenteuerlustig
sie liebt den Wettbewerb fährt
Autorennen je schneller desto besser ein
Multitalent auch abseits der Piste
es gibt überhaupt nichts was eine
probiert hat das ist mein Liebster Pokal
dann habe ich beim Tontaubenschießen und
nicht beim Skifahren gewonnen und habe
das Glück gehabt dass ich so ein Ding
getroffen habe
Rosi Mittermeier bleibt immer normal
bescheiden frei
zweimal Gold einmal Silber damals in
Innsbruck
großartig ja aber was soll's aber wer
Glück gehabt also es ist mir wirklich
ziemlich äußeren Schoß gefallen
und so tritt sie auf ihrem absoluten
Höhepunkt zurück fädelt sich leichtfüßig
in ein neues Leben ein und heiratet
ihren Jugendfreund den Skifahrer
Christian Neureuther
ein bayerischer Traum zwei Kinder
intakte Familie Sohn Felix greift auch
zu den Skiern Idylle im Haus am Hang in
Garmisch verbunden mit dem echten Leben
das Handy dass sie Kastel nennt war
bestenfalls ein Fotoapparat das ist so
vergeude die Zeit ich schaue auf das
Kastel da Konni dabei woanders
hinschauen
lieber Blume an in meinem Garten
wo sie Mittermeier engagierte sich
ehrenamtlich versprühte Lebenslust und
war leidenschaftlich für Gesundheit und
Bewegung immer geerdet hilfsbereit
populär bis zum Ende weil sie im besten
Sinne eine Seele von Mensch war wenn man
so zurückblicken kann auf erleben wie
ich erleben durfte muss ich sagen da
kann man eigentlich nur dankbar sein
ihre Heimat den bayerischen Bergen blieb
sie ein Leben lang treu aber vor allem
sich selbst
das war es von uns weiter geht es mit
dem zweiten Teil unserer zdf-reportage
Maren nostrum wem gehört das Mittelmeer
um 0.45 gibt es dann unser heute schon
mal Update mit Christopher Wehrmann und
hier erwarten Sie morgens und eine
Gellinek bis dahin auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter des milde Januar
Wetter setzt sich weiter fort und die
Strömung dreht jetzt wieder auf Südwest
und hier wird dann die milde Luft
angezapft aber es gibt auch Regen der
allmählich ostwärts zieht und das gibt's
schon in der kommenden Nacht von
Südwesten herkommen kompakte Wolken auf
mit Regen ganz im Osten ist es zunächst
nur trocken und im Süden bildet sich
Nebel Temperaturen sinken auf zwei Grad
am Alpenrand und noch etwas kälter wird
es nach Osten hin mit 0 Grad 9 Grad
Milch bleibt es am Niederrhein morgen
gibt's dann kräftige Schauer Richtung
Nordsee und generell Richtung Nordwesten
im Osten ist es deutlich kompakter
bewölkt und hier regnet es ebenfalls und
auch im Westen ganz im Süden Richtung
Alpenrand da zeigt sich die Sonne bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 6 Grad
Richtung Ostsee generell sind wir häufig
dreistelligen Bereich 13 Grad gibt es im
Westen und 14 am Oberrhein Milz geht es
in den nächsten Tagen weiter am Samstag
häufig trocken nur ganz im Norden
kompakte Wolken mit Regen bei 5 bis 13
Grad am Sonntag erreicht uns ein neues
Regengebiet von Südwesten her dehnt sich
nach Norden hinaus ja und das bei vier
bis zwölf Grad und Montag ebenfalls nass
und etwas kühler und damit wünsche ich
Ihnen einen schönen Abend